- [Announcer] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(gentle music)
- Good afternoon everyone, and welcome.
I'm Mary Comerio, professor
of the Graduate School
and Chair of the Hitchcock
Professorship Committee.
We are pleased, along
with the Graduate Council,
to present Steven Pinker,
this year's speaker
in the Charles M and Martha
Hitchcock Lecture series.
As a condition of this
bequest we are obligated
and happy to tell you how the endowment
came to UC Berkeley.
It is a story that
exemplifies the many ways
the campus is linked to
the history of California
and to the Bay Area.
Dr. Charles Hitchcock, a
physician from the Army,
came to San Francisco
during the Gold Rush,
where he opened a thriving practice.
In 1885 Charles established a
professorship here at Berkeley
as an expression of his
long-held interest in education.
His daughter, Lillie Hitchcock Coit,
still treasured in San Francisco
for her colorful personality
as well as her generosity,
greatly expanded her
father's original gift
to establish a professorship
at UC Berkeley.
Making it possible for us to
present a series of lectures.
The Hitchcock Fund has become
one of the most cherished endowments
of the University of California,
recognizing the highest distinction
of scholarly thought and achievement.
Thank you, Lillie and Charles.
And now a few words about Steven Pinker.
Steven Pinker is an
experimental psychologist
and one of the world's
foremost writers on language,
mind, and human nature.
He is well known for his contributions
to the field of evolutionary psychology
and computational theory of mind.
Pinker has conducted
extensive experimental
and theoretical research
on the acquisition,
processing, history, and
neural basis of language.
Pinker has also conducted research
in the field of visual cognition,
investigating phenomena
such as the mind's ability
to imagine shapes and recognize faces.
His most recent research
investigates the phenomena
of common knowledge and how
it can explain cooperation,
nonverbal communication,
innuendo, euphemism,
and other forms of indirect speech.
Pinker's 2011 book, The
Better Angels of Our Nature,
you see that title here,
Why Violence Has Declined,
advances the bold thesis
that violence as a whole
has declined over the
course of world history.
Drawing from a wide
range of empirical data,
Pinker argues that a
combination of historical forces
has shifted the psychological balance
between motives for violence,
such as exploitation, revenge,
dominance, and sadism,
and motives for avoiding violence,
particularly empathy, self-control,
moral norms, and reason.
Pinker's publications
range from highly technical
academic works to book-length projects
for the general public.
In 1994 he published
The Language Instinct,
a comprehensive account of language
that uncovers its workings
in a biological adaption.
His 1997 book, How the Mind Works,
expands the scope of the first work
to include vision, reasoning, emotions,
social relationship,
and our response to art.
He has since authored
three additional books,
The Blank Slate, The Stuff of Thought,
and The Better Angels of Our Nature.
In addition to his academic work
he is a frequent contributor
to the New Republic,
the New York Times, and Time magazine.
Pinker holds the title of Johnstone Family
Professor of Psychology
at Harvard University.
A long-standing resident
of Cambridge and Boston,
he received his PhD from Harvard in 1976,
and since then he has held
positions at both Harvard and MIT
with brief appointments at
Stanford and sabbatical visits
to University of California Santa Barbara.
His work has received numerous prizes,
from the National Academy of Sciences,
the Royal Institution of Great Britain,
the Cognitive Neuroscience Society,
and the American
Psychological Association.
He holds seven honorary doctorates
and was named the 2006
Humanist of the Year
by the American Humanist Association.
Please join me in welcoming Steven Pinker.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Mary, thanks
to all of you for coming.
Believe it or not, and I
know most people do not,
violence has been in decline
for long stretches of time,
and we may be living in
the most peaceful era
in our species' existence.
The decline of violence
has not been steady.
It has not brought rates
of violence down to zero.
And it is not guaranteed to continue.
But I hope to persuade you
that it is a persistent
historical development,
visible on scales from millennia to years,
from wars and genocides
to the treatment of children and animals.
I'm gonna walk you through
six major historical declines of violence.
First, try to identify
their immediate causes,
that is particular
historical events of the era,
and then try to tie them together
in terms of their ultimate causes,
namely general historical forces
interacting with human nature.
The first decline of violence
I call the pacification process.
Until about 6,000 years ago
humans everywhere lived in anarchy,
without central government.
What was life like in
this state of nature?
This is a question that
thinkers have pondered
for hundreds of years.
In 1651 Thomas Hobbes famously wrote
that in a state of nature the life of man
is "solitary, poor, nasty,
brutish, and short."
A century later, Jean-Jacques
Rousseau countered
that "Nothing could be more gentle
"than man in his primitive state."
Now both of these gentlemen
were speculating from the armchair,
neither of them had any
idea what life was like
in a state of anarchy.
But today we can do better
because there are two sources of evidence
on rates of violent death
in non-state societies.
The first is forensic archeology.
You can think of this as CSI: Paleolithic.
Namely, what proportion
of prehistoric skeletons
have signs of violent trauma,
such as bashed in skulls, decapitations,
bones with arrowheads embedded in them,
or mummies found with
ropes around their necks.
I've assembled here a list
of 20 of these estimates,
plotted in terms of percentage
of deaths due to warfare.
They span quite a range but
they average out to be 15%.
15% of skeletons in these samples
show signs of violent trauma.
Is 15% a big number or a small number?
Well let's compare it to
some comparable figures
from modern eras.
Here we have the rate of
death from war in Europe
and the United States in the 20th century,
including all of the deaths
from both World Wars,
which comes out to be 2/3 of 1%.
If you try to get the
upper bounded estimate,
the largest plausible estimate
of the number of people
who died in the 20th century from wars,
genocides, and man-made famines,
you can push the figure up to about 3%.
And here is the figure for
the world in the 21st century.
The bar is invisible because
it is less than one pixel high,
with a rate of 3/100 of 1%.
The second source of
evidence on rates of violence
in non-state societies
comes from ethnographic vital statistics.
Now the wave of settlement and government
that swept over the world
starting around 6,000 years ago
left a few pockets of the world
still in a state of anarchy,
namely hunter-gatherer,
hunter-horticulturalist,
and other tribal societies.
And ethnographers who have lived with them
for long stretches of time
have recorded their vital statistics,
including causes of death,
including death by warfare
and other forms of violence.
I've found in the literature
27 of these estimates,
and once again they span quite a range.
They average out to be a little more than
500 per hundred thousand per year,
that is every year about
1/2 of 1% of the population
dies in warfare.
Again, is that a big
number or a small number?
Let me put it into perspective
by citing some modern figures
and stack the deck against modernity
by picking some of the
most violent countries
in their most violent periods.
Like Germany in the 20th
century, with its two World Wars,
which comes out to a rate of 144
per hundred thousand per year.
Russia in the 20th century,
two World Wars and a civil war
with a rate of 135.
Japan in the 20th century,
which underwent a World War
that ended in two nuclear
strikes, with a rate of 27.
United States in the 20th century,
which fought two World
Wars and half a dozen
other foreign wars, with a rate of 2.7.
Again if we try to get
the highest plausible rate
for the world as a whole
in the 20th century,
throwing in not just the war deaths
but the deaths from
genocide, man-made famines,
and indirect deaths from
starvation and disease
in the wake of war we
get a rate of about 60.
And here is the figure for
the world in the 21st century.
Again the bar is less than one pixel high.
So not to put too fine a point on it,
but when it comes to violence
in a state of nature,
Hobbes was right, Rousseau was wrong.
The immediate cause was the
rise and expansion of states
and empires, leading to the various paxes
that history students read about.
The Pax Romana, Pax Islamica,
Pax Hispanica, and so on.
The immediate cause is that
tribal raiding and feuding
are a nuisance to imperial overlords.
Not that they have a benevolent interest
in the welfare of their citizens,
but they would just as
soon keep them alive
to supply them with taxes
and soldiers and slaves.
So just as a farmer has a selfish interest
in preventing his livestock
from killing each other,
he doesn't really care
what they're fighting about
and it's just a dead loss to him,
so the first kings and emperors
tried to pacify the territories
that they conquered.
Now the second decline of
violence can be appreciated
by considering this woodcut,
showing a typical day in
the life in the Middle Ages.
And the process that brought
this mayhem under control
has been called the civilizing process.
Turns out that in many parts
of Europe data on homicide
go back literally 800 years.
And historical criminologists
have plotted them over time
when they have found them.
This is a set of homicide
estimates from the year 1200
to the year 2000,
once again plotted in
terms of number of deaths
per hundred thousand per year.
In this case the scale is logarithmic,
from a tenth of a homicide
per hundred thousand per year,
to one to 10 to a 100.
And as you can see there's
been a massive decline
in the rate of homicide in England.
So that a contemporary Englishman
has about 1/35 the chance
of being murdered as
his medieval ancestors.
This is true not just in
England but in every country
for which data are available.
Here we have comparable data
for Germany and Switzerland,
Netherlands, Italy, and Scandinavia.
Here I've averaged those five
regions in Western Europe
and for the sake of
comparison have also included
that 524 per hundred
thousand per year figure
from the average of non-state societies.
So this gap is pretty much what I call
the pacification process.
And this further decline
the civilizing process.
I borrowed the term from a classic book
by the German sociologist Norbert Elias,
who argued that in the
transition from the Middle Ages
to modernity there was a
consolidation of central states
and kingdoms out of the patchwork quilt
of duchies and baronies and principalities
that had polka-dotted Europe.
With it criminal justice was nationalized,
and the constant feuding and
brigandage and war lording
of medieval knights gradually gave way
to the King's justice.
Also during this era
there was a growing
infrastructure of commerce.
There were financial instruments
like money and contracts
that could be recognized
within the boundaries
of the newly consolidated states.
And there were physical
improvements to the infrastructure
of trade such as better roads and carts
and instruments of timekeeping.
As a result, Elias
argued, zero-sum plunder
began to give way to positive-sum trade.
And that's an idea that I'll return to
at the end of the talk as
I try to wrap things up.
The third decline of
violence can be appreciated
by recalling some of the
ways that the early kings
and emperors kept law and
order within their borders.
Namely sadistic forms of
corporal and capital punishment
such as breaking on the
wheel, burning at the stake,
clawing with iron hooks,
sawing in half, and impalement.
But in a development that's been called
the Humanitarian Revolution,
region after region
abolished these forms
of sadistic punishment.
Here we have a timeline
of countries or empires
that abolished torture as a
form of capital punishment.
Including our own country in
the famous Eighth Amendment
prohibition of cruel
and unusual punishment,
which occurred in the
midst of this process,
concentrated in the second
half of the 18th century.
A process that in part has been documented
by the historian Lynn Hunt,
who I believe is here at Berkeley.
Also abolished during this
period was the profligate use
of the death penalty
for non-lethal crimes.
In 18th century England there
were 222 capital offenses
on the books, including
poaching, counterfeiting,
robbing a rabbit warren, being
in the company of gypsies,
and "strong evidence of malice in a child
"seven to 14 years of age."
By 1861 the number of
capital crimes in England
had been reduced to four.
Similarly in 17th and
18th century United States
the death penalty was prescribed and used
for theft, sodomy, bestiality, adultery,
witchcraft, concealing
birth, slave revolt,
and counterfeiting.
There are in this country
capital punishment geeks
who keep databases of every execution
that has ever taken place
in the United States,
including the colonies prior to 1776.
I've taken one of their data sets
and plotted the percentage of executions
in the United States for
crimes other than murder
from 1650 to 2000.
As you can see in the colonial period,
and the early days of the Republic,
a majority of executions were
for crimes other than murder.
Now the only crime punished
by death other than murder
is conspiracy to commit murder.
Now the death penalty itself
of course has been abolished
in every Western democracy
but the United States.
Here we have a timeline
of the European countries
with capital punishment on the books.
Now most of the abolitions
were actually in the 20th century,
but if you look at the blue timeline
it shows the number of European countries
that actually de facto
carried out executions.
Showing that well before
European politicians
got around to striking capital
punishment from the law books
their countrymen had pretty
much lost their taste
for putting people to death.
And on average 50 years elapsed
between the last actual
execution in a European country
and the formal abolition.
Now I mentioned that the United States
is a notorious exception,
or more accurately,
32 of the 50 states are exceptions.
Because the general trend
in the United States
is for state after state to
abolish capital punishment.
Over the course of writing Better Angels
I had to revise the
number of American states
that have capital punishment three times
because of abolitions just
in the last five years.
But even putting aside
the number of states
that have capital punishment,
the number of people who
are actually executed
has been in precipitous decline.
Again this graph goes from
1625 to the year 2000,
showing the number of American
executions per capita.
For all its notoriety
every year in this country
about 40 people are put
to death in a country
that has more than 16,000
homicides every year.
Also abolished during the
Humanitarian Revolution
were witch hunts, religious persecution,
such as burning heretics,
dueling among men of honor,
blood sports like bear
baiting, debtors' prisons,
and most famously of all, slavery.
Slavery used to be legal
everywhere on earth.
No one seemed to think
there's anything
particularly wrong with it.
The Bible had no problem with slavery.
So-called democratic Athens
was a slaveholding society.
But beginning with the second
half of the 18th century
there was a trickle of
abolitions that grew into a flood
that eventually encompassed
the entire world.
Culminating in 1962 when
Saudi Arabia and Yemen
abolished slavery, and finally 1980,
Mauritania became the
last country on earth
to allow slavery as a legal institution.
So for the last three decades
we've been living in
an unprecedented period
in human history in which
slavery has been illegal
everywhere on earth.
What were the immediate causes
of the Humanitarian Revolution?
Well a plausible hypothesis is affluence.
Perhaps as people's lives
become more pleasant,
thanks to the advances in technology,
people put a higher
value on their own lives
and by extension on the lives of others.
I think this is a plausible hypothesis,
but the timing doesn't really work.
Because economic historians tell us
that the increase in material well-being
only really started to take
off in the 19th century,
with the advent of the
Industrial Revolution.
Whereas most of these humanitarian reforms
took place in the 18th century.
You can't see the lines
that I've drawn here,
they're a little bit too faint,
but during this period
there's virtually no real economic growth,
and that's when people started to realize
that burning heretics and
smashing people's arms and limbs
on the wheel may not be the
best way to run a society.
I think that another hypothesis,
one in part advanced by
Lynn Hunt here at Berkeley,
is more plausible and that the
rise of printing and literacy
at least antedated the
humanitarian revolution
and therefore is a more
plausible hypothesis
about its cause.
Prior to the 18th century
there was a 25-fold increase
in the economic efficiency
in producing books.
It's the only industry that
showed an increase in efficiency
prior to the Industrial Revolution.
This technology was put into practice,
and in the 18th century there
was an exponential increase
in the number of books
published per decade.
A kind of early version of Moore's Law.
And in the 18th century,
for the first time,
a majority of Europeans
could read those books.
This was the era in which literacy rate
first surpassed the 50% mark.
Why should literacy matter?
Well there's another name for this era,
it's also called the Enlightenment.
Because this was the
era in which knowledge
began to replace
superstition and ignorance.
And it's not implausible that a literate
and educated populace is less likely
to believe in nonsense such as
that the Jews poisoned the
wells, heretics go to hell,
crop failures are caused by witches,
children are possessed by the devil,
which has to be beaten out of them,
Africans are brutish and
fit only for slavery.
And that's bound to undermine
many rationales for violence.
As Voltaire said during this era,
"Those who can make
you believe absurdities
"can make you commit atrocities."
Also, as Hunt points out,
literacy is a technology
of cosmopolitanism,
of the mixing of people and ideas.
And it is not implausible,
I'll return to this
later in the talk, that the
consumption of fiction and drama
and history and journalism
gets people into the habit
of inhabiting other people's minds.
They try to imagine what
it's like to be someone else.
And conceivably that could
lead to less dehumanization,
less cruelty, and an
expanded sense of empathy.
OK, the fourth historical
decline of violence
has been called the Long Peace.
And it speaks to the
frequently made assertion
that the 20th century was
the most violent in history.
One reads this all the
time, it's a popular meme,
but it turns out that there
are no data in support of it,
that no one cites numbers
from any other century.
So this is a trend based on one point.
And in fact there are many
reasons to doubt that it is true.
Even looking at the so-called
peaceful 19th century,
which is often held up by comparison
as more peaceful than the 20th century,
the case is not so clear.
The so-called peaceful 19th
century had the Napoleonic Wars,
after the World Wars,
the most destructive war
in European history,
with 4 million deaths.
The Taiping Rebellion in China,
the most destructive civil war
in history, with 20 million.
The most destructive
war in American history
took place in the 19th century,
namely the American Civil War.
In Africa we have the
conquests of Shaka Zulu,
which killed perhaps
1 to 2 million people.
In South America we have
the most destructive
interstate war in history,
proportionally speaking,
the War of the Triple Alliance,
which may have killed 60% of
the population of Paraguay.
Not to mention slave-raiding
wars in Africa,
and imperial wars in Africa,
Asia, and the South Pacific,
for which numbers aren't even available.
Also, while it is undoubtedly
true that the worst event
in the 20th century, World War II,
was the deadliest event in human history
in terms of absolute
number of people killed,
it's not so clear that it
was the worst in history
in terms of the percentage
of the world's population
that was affected.
A lot of people were
killed in World War II
but there were a lot of people
around in those days as well.
Here I've taken a dataset from a man
who calls himself an
atrocitologist, Matthew white,
from his book the Great Big
Book of Horrible Things.
And it includes an appendix consisting of
the hundred worst things
that people have ever done to one another.
And I've just scaled them by
the population of the world
at the midpoint of the atrocity.
It goes from 500 BCE to 2,000 CE.
And as you can see
history's worst atrocities
were pretty evenly sprinkled
over 2,500 years of human history.
World War II comes in at ninth place,
World War I doesn't even make the top 10.
Now you can't fail to notice
the data cloud funnels downward
as you get closer to the present,
but presumably this doesn't
mean that in ancient times
they only committed really big atrocities,
and more recently we've
been committing medium-sized
and small-sized ones as well.
Much more likely this is a reflection
of the historical record.
Namely that the farther back you go
the more likely it is that the small stuff
would not have been recorded by historians
and passed down to the present.
If we put a magnifying
glass on the last 500 years,
the era of the printing press,
for which the data are more complete,
we can take a finer grained
look at trends in war.
In particular, Great Power
war, these are the wars
between the 800-pound gorillas of the day,
the states that have the capacity
to project military force
beyond their own boundaries.
And the political scientist Jack Levy
has assembled such a data set.
The first graph shows, from
the year 1500 to the present,
the proportion of years
that the Great Powers
fought each other, the
clashes of the titans.
And it shows that several centuries ago
the Great Powers were pretty much always
at war with each other.
That's just what Great Powers did,
they fought other Great Powers.
More recently they've hardly ever been
at war with each other.
Here we have a graph
showing the duration of wars
involving a Great Power
on at least one side.
And it shows a decline
in how long wars lasted.
History used to have things
like the Thirty Years War
and the Eighty Years War
and the Hundred Years War.
The 20th century had the Six Day War.
Here we have a graph showing
the frequency of wars
involving a Great Power.
How often would a Great Power pick a fight
that resulted in a war.
And that has been in
decline over 500 years.
There is however one trend
that went in the opposite direction
over most of this period.
That is, once a Great
Power did start a war,
how good was it at killing
lots of people quickly?
That is what is the rate
of death per country,
per war per year.
And because of advances,
I guess if you can call them that,
in military organization and weaponry,
wars when they did break out
got deadlier and deadlier,
up to the climax of World War II,
at which even this curve does a U-turn.
And for the last 2/3 of a century
wars have become less deadly
as well as being shorter
and less frequent.
If you multiply these figures together
and just look at the
aggregate number of people
killed in Great Power wars,
and I'm sorry, I should
have mentioned this earlier.
An important statistical fact
about the distribution of deaths in wars
is that the biggest wars
kill the most people.
That is once you account
for the Great Power wars
you've accounted for a
majority of all the people
who are killed in all wars combined,
including the smaller ones.
Well here's what you get, you
get kind of a zigzaggy curve,
but one for which the
lowest point in 500 years
is the most recent quarter-century.
We can then zoom in on
the last hundred years
for which the data are richer yet again,
being closer to the present.
And here's a look at the 20th century
and the first decade of the 21st century.
There is no question that there were two
horrific spikes of bloodshed
in the 20th century
centered around the two World Wars.
But far from being a crescendo
that would lead to an even worse war,
since World War II the
bottom has kind of fallen out
and the curve bumps along the X-axis.
This is the period that
historians have called
the Long Peace.
The fact that since 1946 there's been
a historically unprecedented
decline in interstate war,
wars with a government on each side.
In fact the most interesting
statistic from this period
is zero, that refers to the number of wars
between the two greatest
powers of them all,
the United States and the Soviet Union,
which never fought a direct
war against each other.
Contrary as those of us
who remember this era,
contrary to every expert who
predicted that World War III,
between the US and the Soviet Union,
was inevitable, but it never happened.
No nuclear weapon has
been used since Nagasaki.
Again, contrary to every expert prediction
that a thermonuclear World
War was just a matter of time.
There have been no wars
between any two Great Powers
since 1953, more than 50 years ago,
the end of the Korean War.
60 years ago, I'm sorry.
There have been no wars between any two
Western European countries since 1945,
a fact that we almost take for
granted as banal and obvious.
Like, you know, who would ever expect say,
Germany and France to fight a war?
But needless to say this is a historically
highly unusual state of affairs.
Prior to 1945, Western
European countries alone
started two new wars for 600 years.
As of 1945 that fell to zero.
And there have been no wars
between developed countries
for the last 2/3 of a century.
The 44 countries with the
highest GDP per capita
have not fought a war against each other.
Again, if that sounds obvious to you,
like you know, war,
that's the kind of thing
that happens in those poor, backward,
southern hemisphere kind of countries,
that shows the magnitude
of the historical change.
For much of human history it
was the big rich countries
that were constantly at
each other's throats.
And because big rich countries
can afford big destructive armies
they could rack up an awful
lot of deaths quickly.
Well what about the rest of the world?
I've spoken about Great Power wars,
I've spoken about wars
involving rich countries.
But in a development that
I call the New Peace,
the Long Peace seems to be spreading
to the rest of the world.
Now since 1946, as I've mentioned,
there have been fewer interstate wars,
country against country.
There have however been more civil wars,
starting in the 1960s,
a trend that went in
the opposite direction,
as newly independent states
with inept governments
defended themselves against
insurgent movements,
with both sides armed,
financed, and egged on
by the US and the Soviet Union.
But after the Cold War
the number of civil wars declined as well.
So the question is which
wars kill more people,
the interstate wars, which
have been petering out,
or the civil wars, which
grew and then began to recede
during the '60s, '70s, and '80s.
And this graph gives you the answer.
First I'm showing you a
number of bars that correspond
to the rate of death in interstate wars,
country against country, in each decade,
from the '50s, '60s, '70s,
'80s, '90s, and 2000s.
Here we have the corresponding figure
for internationalized civil war,
civil wars in which some
third party butts in,
usually to help the
government defend itself.
And here we have the rate of death
from purely internal civil wars.
So as you can see the
decline in the death rate
from interstate wars has
not been compensated for
by nearly as much of an
increase in the death rate
from civil wars.
What if you then put these together,
the number of wars of each kind,
multiplied by the deadliness of each war?
Well here's a graph showing
the overall trajectory
of deaths in wars of
all kinds put together.
And it's a stacked layer graph
where the thickness of each layer
corresponds to the rate of death from war
in one of each of four categories.
And the height of the entire stack
shows the proportion of
the world's population
that's killed in all wars combined.
So first we have colonial wars,
where a European empire tried
to hang on to its colonies,
and that tapered off to zero in the 1970s.
Here are the deaths from interstate wars,
country against country,
with spikes corresponding
to the Korean War,
the Vietnam War, and the Iran-Iraq War.
Here we have the rate of death
from purely internal civil wars
and from internationalized civil wars.
So we have something of a rollercoaster,
with a number of local reversals,
but the overall trajectory
has been downward and here
we are in the 21st century
with a thin laminate of
layers of wars of all kind,
showing that we're living in an era
in which fewer people that
ever before are dying in war.
Now what about in the last five years?
2008 was the year with the last figures
that were available to
me when I sent my book,
Better Angels of Our Nature,
off to the publishers.
I've recently updated the
graph with more recent figures
addressing the concern
that with the Arab Spring
and the wars in its wake,
particularly the civil war in Syria,
have we seen a reversal.
And the answer is that
we have a little bit.
See this little uptick here,
that reflects the number of
deaths from among other things
the civil war in Syria.
But overall it doesn't come
anywhere close to reversing
the long-term trend since
the end of World War II.
Well what were the immediate
causes of the Long Peace
and the New Peace?
Three of them were advanced
more than two centuries ago
by Immanuel Kant in his
essay Perpetual Peace,
in which he argued that
democracy, international trade,
and an international community
all disincentivized leaders
from dragging their countries
into stupid wars.
More recently the political
scientists Bruce Russett
and John Oneal have
tested Kant's hypotheses
quantitatively in a large data
set of militarized disputes.
And they argue that the data
show that Kant got it right
three out of three times.
That all three of these
factors have increased
over the course of the second
half of the 20th century.
And all of them are statistical predictors
of peace down the line,
holding constant every
other conceivable variable.
The final decline of violence
I call the Rights Revolutions.
And this refers to the
targeting of violence
on smaller scales, directed
against vulnerable sectors
of the population such
as African Americans
and other racial
minorities, women, children,
homosexuals, and animals.
The civil rights revolution first of all
put and end to the practice of lynching.
Lynchings used to take
place in this country
at a rate of 150 a year.
That's three a week at the
end of the 19th century.
By the 1950s that rate had fallen to zero.
More recently the FBI
has been keeping track
of hate crime violence directed
against African Americans,
such as intimidation and assault.
And all three have been in decline
since records were first kept in the 90s.
And the kind of racist attitudes
that licensed violence against minorities
has also been in steady decline.
This graph shows the results
of two sets of opinion polls
asking white Americans the
question, do you believe
that black and white students
should go to separate schools,
and if a black family moved in
next door would you move out?
In the 1940s a majority of
people favored racial segregation
and close to a majority would move out
if a black family moved next door.
That has been in steady
decline to the point
that the positive results
fall into the range of crank opinion,
and the pollsters have just
eliminated the question
from their surveys.
This is not just an American phenomenon,
but may be part of a worldwide trend.
This graph shows the number of countries
that have apartheid or Jim
Crow laws on their books
that discriminate against
their ethnic minorities.
The blue line shows
the number of countries
that bend over backwards
in the other direction,
that have various affirmative action
or remedial discrimination policies
designed to boost their
disadvantaged minorities.
And so for the last few years
there have been more countries
whose laws favor their minorities
than countries that
discriminate against them.
The women's rights
movement has brought about
an 80% reduction in the rate of rape
since statistics were
first kept in the 1970s.
A similarly precipitous decline
in rates of domestic
violence against women.
And declines in the most extreme
form of domestic violence
of all, namely uxoricide,
the murder of female romantic partners,
and mariticide, the murder
of male romantic partners.
If anything the decline is
even steeper for male victims
than for female victims, showing
that the women's movement
has been very very good for husbands.
The children's rights movement
has seen a steady decline
in the use of corporal
punishment in schools,
strapping and paddling.
Where now a minority of states,
concentrated in the South,
even allow the practice.
Public opinion polls that ask people
whether it is acceptable to spank a child
have all shown declines.
Rates of child abuse are down,
both physical abuse and sexual abuse.
And rates of violence in
which children are victims,
such as fights and
non-fatal crimes in schools.
The gay rights movement
has seen an increase
in the number of states
that have decriminalized homosexuality.
Not just states worldwide
but American states,
which now stands at 50 out of 50
thanks to a Supreme Court decision.
Anti-gay attitudes such as, is
homosexuality morally wrong,
should it be criminalized,
and should gay people be
denied equal opportunity,
have all shown steady declines.
And the animal rights movement,
finally, has seen a decline
in hunting, an increase in vegetarianism,
both in the UK and the US,
and a sharp decline in the
number of motion pictures
in which animals were harmed.
Well this raises the question
why is violence declined
on so many scales of time and magnitude?
Now one possibility is that
human nature has changed
and somehow our violent inclinations
have literally been bred out of us.
Well I consider this hypothesis coherent
but empirically unlikely.
For one thing we continue
to see violence in children.
Almost half of two-year-olds
kick, bite, and hit.
And rough-and-tumble play
is one of the most robust
sex differences observed cross-culturally.
Our grown-up children continue
to enjoy various forms
of vicarious violence
such as murder mysteries,
Greek tragedies, Shakespearean dramas,
video games, hockey, and movies starring
a certain ex-governor of this very state.
And then there are homicidal fantasies.
A number of psychologists have
posed the following question
to their subjects.
Have you ever fantasized
about killing someone
you don't like?
And the results are
that about 15% of women
and a third of men frequently fantasize
about killing people.
And about 60% of women and 3/4 of men
at least occasionally
fantasize about killing people.
What does this tell us about human nature,
it tells us that 25% men are liars.
(audience laughing)
A more likely possibility
is that human nature
is extraordinarily complex
and it has always included
both neural systems that
incline us toward violence
and neural systems that counteract them,
what Abraham Lincoln poetically called
the "better angels of our nature."
And that what has changed
over the course of history
is that circumstances
have increasingly favored
our peaceable motives.
Well what are the motives for violence?
Neurobiologists have
known for quite some time
that there is no single
thing called aggression,
that there are multiple
systems in the brain
behind violent acts.
Anyone who owns a cat
knows that when a cat
is preparing for predation
it will quietly stalk a mouse
or a cockroach or maybe
even a hallucination,
and keep low to the ground,
exhibit quiet stalking behavior,
a sudden pounce and a quick bite.
Whereas when one male cat, not neutered,
encounters another male cat,
you get a kind of aggression
that couldn't be more different.
There's a lot of piloerection
and hissing and yowling,
and then perhaps what we call a cat fight.
And we know that these
two forms of aggression
are controlled by different
circuits in the brain.
Stepping back and looking
at the number of motives
for violence in humans
there are four major ones
that I try to lay out in the book.
There's just sheer raw naked exploitation,
the harming of a person that
happens to be an obstacle
on the path to something that you want.
Resulting in forms of
violence such as rape,
plunder, conquest, and
the elimination of rivals.
Very different is the drive for dominance,
the urge among individuals
to climb the pecking order
and become alpha male.
And a corresponding motive among groups
for ethnic, racial, national,
or religious supremacy.
There's a revenge or moralistic violence,
the urge to and the conviction
that it is not just
permissible but mandatory
to harm someone who's
committed a moral infraction,
not to let them get away with it.
Which results in vendettas, rough justice,
and cruel punishment.
Then moving from the
level of the individual
to the social network, there
are utopian ideologies,
ideas or memes that
spread from mind to mind
that can often license
vast amounts of violence,
such as militant religions, nationalism,
Nazism, and communism.
Which licenses violence
by a kind of pernicious
cost-benefit analysis.
What these ideologies have in common
is that they hold out
the prospect of a utopia.
Of a world that will be
infinitely good forever.
Well if you are under the
throes of the conviction
that such a utopia is possible
the ends are infinitely good.
Well then you can commit as
much violence as you want
to bring that kingdom of heaven to earth.
And you're always on the
positive side of the ledger,
you're always doing more good than harm.
And let's say that you
announce your vision
of an infinitely perfect
world and there's some people
who just don't buy it, they
don't get with the program.
How evil are they?
Well they're the only
thing standing in the way
of a world that will be
infinitely good forever.
Well you do the math as to how
much punishment they deserve.
As in the old communist slogan
you can't make an omelet
without breaking eggs.
Which of course ignores the
fact that people are not eggs.
But it does explain the somewhat
superficially paradoxical
fact that the worst
atrocities in human history
were all carried out
in pursuit of a moral,
higher idealistic good.
Well that sounds pretty depressing,
but what do we have on the other side,
what circuits do we
have in the human brain
that can push back against
our violent impulses?
Well there's self-control.
Systems in the prefrontal cortex
that can anticipate the
consequences of behavior
and inhibit our violent impulses.
There's empathy, the ability
to feel others' pain.
Probably underlain by the oxytocin system.
There's a moral sense, a
set of norms and taboos
that govern just what a
decent person considers
within the realm of possibility.
And there's reason.
Cognitive processes that allow us
to engage in objective, detached analysis.
Well having laid out that
psychology of violence
and non-violence, the question now is
how do you bring the psychology
back together with the history?
Which historical developments
bring out our better angels
and stay our hands before they
can commit acts of bloodshed?
One possibility is that
Hobbes got it right
when he called for a Leviathan,
a government with a monopoly
on the legitimate use of force.
Now a state and judicial system
with a monopoly on violence
can reduce actual outbreaks
of violence by first of all
neutralizing the incentive
for exploitative attack
by penalizing aggression
and therefore canceling out
the aggressor's anticipated gain.
That can then calm everyone down
because not only are you deterred
from attacking your neighbors but you know
that your neighbors are
deterred from attacking you.
And so it eliminates the
temptation for a preemptive strike,
to do it to them before they do it to you.
For broadcasting a belligerent
stance of macho strength
in order to establish the
credibility of your deterrent.
And of course eliminates the need
to carry out revenge after the fact.
You can outsource it
to the state and its judicial apparatus.
And in doing so you're not just
trading one kind of violence
for another because outsourcing
revenge to a third party
means that you are circumventing
the self-serving biases
that social psychologists have shown
that all humans are prone to.
Where in any dispute
both sides always believe
that their opponent's attacks
are unprovoked aggression,
out of the blue.
Whereas their own attacks
are justified retaliation
after the fact.
Well when you have both
sides in the throes
of these self-serving illusions
one side can count an
odd number of attacks
and feel that justice must be done.
Another counts an even number
and figures that the scores
have all been settled.
And that can lead to endless cycles
of a blood feud and vendetta.
Cycles which can be nipped in the bud
when it is a disinterested third party
that is assessing the harm
and meting out the punishment.
Some historical evidence comes from
the pacifying and
civilizing effects of states
that I alluded to in historical
trends number one and two.
And the fact that you can
watch this movie in reverse.
When government breaks down
and zones of anarchy emerge,
such as the American Wild West,
where you all remember the
cliche in the cowboy movies,
that the nearest sheriff
is 120 miles away,
so you've got to defend
yourself with your six-shooter.
In failed states, collapsed empires.
And contraband economies
like mafias and street gangs
where you can't file a lawsuit
if you think you've
been cheated in a deal.
You can't dial 911 if you feel threatened.
The only protection is a
willingness and ability
to commit violence to
protect your interests.
And in all of these
cases of zones of anarchy
you have quite obviously
high rates of violence.
A second possibility is the
theory of gentle commerce,
doux commerce, an idea
from the Enlightenment,
that argues that plunder
is a zero-sum game.
The victor's gain is the victim's loss.
Whereas trade is a positive-sum game.
If you exchange your
surpluses then, as we say,
everybody wins.
And as over the course of history
improving technology has
allowed goods and ideas
to be traded over longer distances
among larger groups of
people and at lower cost,
it becomes cheaper to buy
things than to steal them,
and other people become
more valuable to you
alive than dead.
And there is some historical
evidence for this hypothesis.
A number of statistical studies that show
that companies with open
economies and a greater dependence
on international trade fight fewer wars,
host fewer civil wars,
and have fewer genocides.
Holding all other factors constant.
A third hypothesis has been
called the Expanding Circle
in a book by that name by
the philosopher Peter Singer,
but the idea goes back to Charles Darwin.
Namely that humans come
equipped by natural selection
with a sense of empathy.
Unfortunately by default
we apply our empathy
only within a very narrow
circle of friends and families
and cute fuzzy little baby animals.
But over the course of history
one can see the circle
expanding to the village,
the clan, the tribe,
the nation, other races,
both sexes, children, and
perhaps eventually other species.
Well this just begs the question
of why should the circle have expanded.
And I think the technologies
have increased cosmopolitanism
are a plausible cause,
that as people travel
more, consume more history,
more literature and drama
and more journalism,
they are less likely to dehumanize
people unlike themselves
and more likely to imagine
what it's like to be them
and have less of a taste for harming them.
And there is experimental
evidence that when people
adopt a real person's perspective,
or for that matter the perspective
of a fictional character,
they show more sympathy
both to that individual
and to the category that
that individual represents.
A number of social psychology experiments
have replicated that finding.
Finally there's the escalator of reason,
the possibility that
the growth of literacy,
education, and public discourse
has encouraged people
to think more abstractly
and more universally.
We rise above our parochial vantage point.
That makes it harder to
privilege your own interests
over others just because
you're you and they're not.
It encourages people to
stand back and recognize
the futility of cycles of violence.
And increasingly see violence
as a problem to be solved
rather than as a contest to be won.
Some historical evidence
comes from the fact that,
again, believe it or not,
abstract reasoning abilities
as measured by IQ,
increased over the course
of the 20th century.
The so-called Flynn
Effect, by which IQ scores
increased by three points a decade
throughout the 20th century
and all over the world.
And other studies have shown
that people in societies
with higher degrees of education
and measured intelligence
commit fewer crimes, cooperate
more in experimental games,
have more classically liberal attitudes,
such as opposition to homophobia,
racism, and xenophobia,
and are more receptive to
democracy 10 years down the line.
The final question I'll
ask is why would these
and other forces all be
pushing in the same direction?
Why should there be not just one
but several historical developments
that all result in
lower rates of violence?
Now I don't believe in any mysterious,
mystical arc of history or dialectic
or push toward an omega
point of perfect peace.
Rather I think that violence
is what game theorists call
a social dilemma.
Namely it's tempting to an aggressor
to exploit a victim,
but of course the harm done to the victim
is greater than the gains
enjoyed by the aggressor.
Since in the long run
victims become aggressors
and vice versa, all parties
would objectively be better off
if everyone could agree
to refrain from violence.
The dilemma is how do
you get the other guy
to refrain from violence at
the same time that you do.
Because if you beat your
swords into plowshares
but the other guy keeps
his swords as swords,
well you could find
yourself at the wrong end
of an invading army.
It's not implausible to think
that over the course of
history human experience
and human ingenuity have
gradually chipped away
at this problem just as we've
dealt with other scourges
of the human condition,
like pestilence and hunger.
And the common denominator
behind these four pacifying
forces is that all of them
increase the material, emotional,
or cognitive incentives
of all parties to avoid
violence simultaneously.
Well regardless of what
the best explanation
of the decline of violence turns out to be
I think it has implications
that are profound.
For one thing it calls for a
reorientation of our efforts
towards violence reduction
from a moralistic mindset
to an empirical mindset.
Instead of lamenting why is there war,
perhaps the question
we should be asking is,
why is there peace?
Not just what are we doing wrong,
but what have we been doing right?
Because we have been doing something right
and it seems to me to be
quite important to figure out
what exactly it is.
Also the decline of violence
I think calls for a
reassessment of modernity,
of the centuries-long trend
that has eroded family,
tribe, tradition, and religion,
and giving way to individual rights,
cosmopolitanism, reason, and science.
Now, everyone has to acknowledge
that modernity has brought us many gifts.
Longer and healthier lives,
less ignorance and superstition,
richer experiences.
But there's always been
a current of nostalgia
and romanticism that has
questioned the price.
Is it worth it if we have
to live in the shadow
of terrorism, genocide, world
wars, and nuclear weapons?
On the other hand if, despite impressions,
the long-term trend, though
halting and incomplete,
is that violence of all
kinds is decreasing,
I believe this calls for a rehabilitation
of the ideals of modernity and progress.
And it's a cause for gratitude
for the institutions of
civilization and enlightenment
that have made it possible.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
(gentle music)